hey guys how's it going welcome back to
my
christmas cooking segments whatever the
heck you want to call these i'm not even
sure but today i am wearing my finest
target attire i've still got the tag
attached
and i think i'm going to leave this on
throughout the entire video so hopefully
this doesn't interfere with any of my
baking
i thought i would wear this because
today we are making gingerbread
cupcakes i'm pretty excited about this
recipe because i love gingerbread and i
love cupcakes so this is basically
combining all of my two favorite things
i also love target they've got so many
great christmas sweaters like i was
losing my mind i was cartwheeling up and
down
the freaking aisles looking for the
finest deals and i found them this is
not sponsored let's get all of our
ingredients ready and let's
bake so for this recipe we're gonna need
1 3 4 cups of flour
1 teaspoon baking soda two teaspoons
ground cinnamon 1 4 teaspoon ground
cloves
1 4 teaspoon ground nutmeg 2 teaspoons
ground ginger half cup melted butter
half cup brown sugar half cup molasses 1
large egg
half cup of water we've got all of our
ingredients and now we're going to put
everything into the mixer and we're
going to make
some cupcake magic but first i need to
melt this butter because it is not
melted and this is the first time that
it's actually called for melted butter
and i
don't even have the butter melted yet
i'm so unprepared
hurry up is this bad for my brain
i'm gonna start mixing it as we go it's
not plugged in
because i gotta make this mixer move i'm
gonna be on the front page of reddit
fringe
molasses now we gotta put our egg in
oh yeah i'm sweating i'm sweating this
sweater is so hot perfect for a winter
wonderland of which we are not in
because why i'm in los angeles
i'm sweating we don't have winter
we use our star wars whisk and we're
gonna mix our dry
i forgot what all of these were so
reference the beginning if you need to
know
oh we'll just stir this together using
our
wonderful star wars darth vader
whisk now watch me whisk and watch me
and name me
i haven't left the house in a while i'm
baking a lot
so our dry ingredients are now dry and
mixed so we're gonna add our water into
this mixture
and now we're gonna slowly mix this into
here so let's do it it's really
important to scrape the sides because
that's just some extra gingerbread
goodness that you
will be wasting and we don't want it to
go to waste
almost ready let's mix this up just a
little bit more
and then we're gonna put them into a
cupcake tin
okay try that again we've got our
cupcake liners
and we're gonna place those in just like
so cupcakes
lined now we're gonna fill this about
three-fourths full and then we're gonna
bake
for about like 20 or something minutes
let's go
time to fill up our cakes
that's it let's pop these in the oven
and then we're gonna make our
gingerbread frosting
and look at this i've got everything all
prepped and ready for our icing because
this is a professional
kitchen we've got six tablespoons of
butter
all right let's mix this up until it's
nice and
light and fluffy how will i know when
it's light and fluffy
whoa wow let's put a little bit of milk
just to get it real nice and
doing its job oh god okay this is
looking pretty good
all right hey stuff
oh my god this is so good
like i wow now we're gonna mix this up
really good and that'll be our final
mixture and then hopefully our cupcakes
will be done
and we can ice them and we can carry on
this just ruined everything
this is what we need to do we need to
never talk about the tag again
don't talk about the tag don't tell
jenna
all right we're gonna get this icing out
of here i mixed it up really nice
real good i guess i don't really have to
take it out of here but i feel like i
would like a nice presentation
plate of my delicious icing
all right let's take our cupcakes out of
the oven
looks like they're ready now time to ice
these little
babies up we've got plenty to choose
from
let's just juggle our cupcakes before
we put our icing on them because
juggling cupcakes with icing
we've tried that i also made these
little gingerbread men the other day
using that recipe that i previously used
in my making of
youtubers gingerbread and that didn't go
so well either hey jen
hello
you want a cupcake or no i had so many
sweets today but you gotta have one of
these did you eat one yet they look
they look good try the icing it's
delicious i strive for the best here
probably the best icing that i've ever
made in my life
it has another little secret ingredient
what do you think oh is that cinnamon
is that the secret ingredient is it
poison this is probably not my best
icing job i feel like i probably should
have put a little bit
more confectioners sugar in here because
these are very melty
did you put one in there no this is my
gingerbread pocket
okay but you can't put all my gingers in
there
well it's literally the gingerbread box
yeah
it's where they're supposed to go i'm
loving christmas i've got so many
gingerbread accessories
this is super exciting this is so
festive this is something that you can
really make
your friends your family your
enemies depending upon if you follow my
recipe
so we're going to start with the
gingerbreads in my pocket i have just
birthed
several babies one two three four fives
i can't count now we're going to start
by just placing one of these
navy right i think he placed himself
this man did not have a good time in my
pocket
but that's okay we're gonna let you live
out your best life
here you're my friend i shouldn't put
that you look great
give him a little girlfriend why is she
naked i'm confused
all the other ones have clothes on
except the women scandal where's my
where's my pocket gingerbreads okay this
one's gonna be
here i would like for you guys to tweet
this to any of your favorite
people that do uh television talk shows
about food
because they need to see this skill
i gotta go back on kelly and ryan
because i need ryan to see
what my baking skills are made of
because he wasn't there when i went on
the show oh
i'm a diver let's see if i can just
throw this one on
aiming for this one this is kind of like
when you're playing pool and you're like
oh this pocket well i am a freaking
champion okay i'm gonna try this big
cookie
i'm gonna try for this one
well it landed it didn't stick
it's okay i was a gymnast once and not a
very good one
i love christmas
this is the party this is the party that
you all want to go to
right here
now time to do a taste test of our
delicious cupcakes i'm pretty excited
about this
and i'm wondering if jenna would like to
join me no
okay choose wisely my dear super flat
man
yes no set him down we need to give him
the proper treatment okay half for you
half for me
cause i make cupcakes moves
[Music]
it's a nice taste um i preferably i mean
i really enjoy the icing
the cake is a little too caked it's a
little toasty
um i really like what she's doing with
the gingerbread man
um watch it
my microphone's here and she's not miked
so if you're wondering why she's
talking to my chest that's why well guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you guys enjoyed this video i've got a
bunch more christmas videos coming out
for you guys i hope that you enjoy them
if you're not subscribed already be sure
to hit that subscribe button make sure
you hit the bell because that'll alert
you whenever
uh i post new videos if you guys didn't
know that
that's my sister jenna it's me jenna e
she's the best she puts up with a lot
of my shenanigans you guys don't even
know
what i be it i'll write a book one day
[Music]
i'll see you guys later happy holidays
i gotta take the sweater off because i'm
i'm sweating
because i'll make sweaters move oh put
him in the pocket
what's the song where they say this i've
got cause i
got one hand in my pocket the other ones
tossing a cigarette smoking a cigarette
or tossing smoking a cigarette
licking a cigarette
[Music]
hey a cupcake
and then it's christmas day
the joyful times we witness
forever stays hither